Let the Battinson bonanza begin.
When Matt Reeves, the co-writer and director
of the upcoming superhero film The Batman,
shared to Twitter the first camera test of
Robert Pattinson as Gotham's greatest protector,
the internet practically collapsed in on itself.
For a brief moment, it felt as though the
world stopped turning, a sudden halt spurred
by the thousands of tweets sent out by fans
responding to the big reveal.
"Time is a thing that grows scarcer everyday.
What, you don't know this?"
As with any reveal of this sort, one that
gives the world the first official glimpse
of an actor in costume as a beloved, internationally
recognized pop culture figure, reactions to
Pattinson as Batman have been mixed.
The majority of early responses to the reveal
were positive, with countless Twitter users
gushing over the first-look footage.
One user wrote,
"I'm ecstatic.
This movie will be amazing."
Another added that they enjoyed both the way
the Battinson suit looks and the score teased
in the camera test video, writing,
"The Batman teaser looked really dope.
I especially loved the tone that was playing
during it.
Hope to get a fleshed out version of it when
it releases."
Plenty of fans analyzed the video with a keener
eye, picking up on possible references to
Batman's past and to other iterations of the
character.
Comparisons were made between the new Batsuit
for The Batman and the costumes seen in Batman:
Arkham Knight, Arkham Origins, and Batman:
Gotham Knight.
Many also noted that the video felt somewhat
like a tease for a Daredevil project, since
it's dimly lit and doused in a striking red
hue similar to the color of the Marvel hero's
suit.
One Twitter user wrote,
"I'm definitely getting some Daredevil vibes.
The new Batman suit looks incredible for what
it is.
Man I'm so excited for Matt Reeves take on
the character."
One fan, who was actually one of several who
presented this theory, posited that the new
Bat-symbol could be made from a gun, perhaps
the one used to murder Bruce Wayne's parents.
That fan also wrote on Twitter that Pattinson
"looks amazing," and that they "can't wait"
to see The Batman.
Another fan tweeted,
"A simple camera test and I am 300 times more
excited for Pattinson as Batman."
The initial wave of positive reactions to
the Battinson reveal was soon met with a negative
wave, naturally.
Some people slammed the reveal video as "lame"
and "stupid," and used plenty of unsavory
words to criticize the way Pattinson looks
as Batman.
One use tweeted,
"So basically it's yet another ugly armor
suit, only this time they couldn't even be
bothered to make the emblem look good.
Wow.
Is there a rule at WB/DC that no Batman actor
can have a decent-looking costume anymore?"
"These questions are vital ones."
Another fan wrote on Twitter,
"The new Batman suit is ugly if you ask me.
I do like the mask and the collar, but I'm
not a fan of the armor look."
Meanwhile, NRG Esports' Richard "KingRichard"
Nelson didn't mince his words, writing,
"Bruh that Batman reveal is terrible."
This trend of unfiltered reactions to the
reveal continued all across Twitter, with
one fan tweeting,
"Excuse me for my language but that is just
f---ing awful!
I know [Ben] Affleck had doubters, but as
soon as we saw him in the suit, no one, no
one doubted then!
I'm a huge batman fan and this may very well
be the first time I don't go see the movie."
While that fan clearly believes Ben Affleck
was the best Batman and that Pattinson can
never measure up, others have said that seeing
this reveal for The Batman solidifies the
notion that Christian Bale is the best actor
to have stepped into the Batsuit.
One user argued,
"Batman should have ended when Christian bale
stopped playing him.
Stop over killing it!
Affleck was terrible, Robert is out here looking
like daredevil...STOP IT."
All things considered, this feels like a fairly
normal response to a reveal of this caliber.
Some fans have maintained a cool head and
advised others do the same until The Batman
actually opens in theaters.
As one fan tweeted,
"People deciding the new Batman is s--- after
one short teaser image...I thought Guardians
of the Galaxy looked terrible after one image.
A talking raccoon and a tree?
No, thanks.
Yeah, it's one of my favourite films.
Wait and see."
The Batman flies into theaters on June 25,
2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.